what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation were cosplaying Grunkle
John here John's uh gonna sacrifice his
uh reaction Mobility
[Music]
yeah it's not made for these headphones
unfortunately nor are these headphones
made to sit to sit high on top of
someone's hat but it's okay because Fez
is a cool very very stiff body language
John's performance today yeah all right
guys well we have made it to the end of
Gravity Falls I want to thank everyone
who's joined us on this journey it's not
often we complete a whole series my God
I know it's so rare they made it easy
for us yeah they did it a couple Seasons
right yeah I wanted to say thank you
very much to all who support us on
patreon for the watch along with that in
mind the watch along will be public
sorry I'm just really uh getting all
emotional there now okay I will put a
link in the description box for you all
uh so you can do that but thank you to
all who have supported us I contributed
to our patreon page there but all we ask
for now is you leave a like and um let's
just enjoy it it's the final final
episode oh my God I don't really know
what to expect from the ending like how
is it going to end like I know we got a
villain we gotta defeat but what's the
ending like order to the last like five
minutes
is what I'm like I have no idea what
it's going to be I'm just going back
home leaving it all behind
all right guys
let's roll that intro
[Music]
oh this is just too perfect didn't you
brainiacs know the Zodiac doesn't work
if you don't I'll hold hands the Zodiac
every threat to my power together and
one easy to destroy Circle
oh no oh no
you guys want to see what happens to
your friends when you can't get along
not really
come back you
oh but you should be
[Music]
ultimate possession oh no you know this
Castle could really use some decorations
oh my God dang it's like Nazi symbolism
I know
chance tell me how to take weirdmageddon
Global and I'll spare the kids no don't
do it yeah Bill makes bad deals
I see everything
and why every time Nice Shot pumpkin
yeah
I know that hurts because I've
accidentally done it to myself
yes oh awesome
[Applause]
[Music]
you got this kids
come and get us you pointy jerk
red bill
no it's too dangerous
not so fast you two wait here
children I need to be wow
my God he is horrifying
it's like Pennywise yeah he really is
on you kids I'm gonna disassemble
dang where are you going I'm gonna play
the only card we have left let bill into
my mind he'll be able to take over the
Galaxy and maybe even worse but at least
he might let the kids free what are you
kidding me are you honestly telling me
there's nothing else we could do let the
kids die you need to take his deal it's
the only way he'll agree to save you and
the kids do you really think he's gonna
make good on that deal what other choice
do we have
but the plate
starting to think there's no way out of
here like Uncle Stan always says when
one door closes choose a nearby wall and
fashion it oh yeah
yeah and Maple
[Music]
now let's round up the town spot and
together we can defeat oh no
shrink all the Baddies
yikes I got the kids
I think I'm gonna kill one of them now
just for the heck of it no
maybe
find me
you ain't
I Surrender
good choice
that could have killed him yeah my only
condition is that you let my brother and
the kids go fine go to live in a
hellscape
[Music]
wow
oh I'm here I'm finally here
this is so trippy you really know how to
clear your I switched clothes and stuff
what impersonated each other a pretty
good impression of my brother don't I
which clothes and no one can tell us
apart Welcome to My Mind surprised you
didn't recognize it
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh too late for that sucker what's gonna
happen to Grunkle Stander memory gun
pretty clever huh
don't you realize you're destroying your
own mind too it's not like I was using
the space for much anyway let me out of
here oh
but the summer all the memories you're
making a mistake I'll give you anything
funny bainbridge's infinite power your
own Galaxy please
[Applause]
oh my god oh nice I did not expect this
no he sacrificed everything yeah yeah I
guess I was good for something after all
he didn't go after the greed or any of
that
[Music]
they'll snap their necks
John we what do we say about Mobility
we're good we're good
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh no oh he got the Terminator goodbye
hey there kiddo what's your name Grunkle
Stan
who are you talking to
come on it's me it's me fungal stand
oh there's gotta be something in the
book Stan has no idea but he did it
oh
our hero Stanley
oh
there's got to be a way
oh
hey why the long faces you guys look
like it's someone's funeral who's that
big guy crying in the corner
I
like uncle's in there somewhere there's
got to be something around here that can
help bring them back smart
[Music]
here's the first day we came to Gravity
Falls Uncle stance season one
emotions
it's a clip show I'm sorry I don't know
what this is or who you are quit it
Waddles I'm trying to remember
what did you say I said get Waddles off
of me it's working keep reading Waddles
it's that remaining Neil deGrasse Tyson
in there yeah
everyone is impressed by and more
important is I've met some neighborhood
hotties
oh the end
get out of here you ordering Critters
[Applause]
good as new at least they all know the
truth
round about the events of the last few
days what do we say
never mind all that and if you break the
dudes we're gonna zap you slap zap we're
mad with power
they did it they did it they're gonna
use those tasers tonight
Preston Northwest had to sell his
Mansion to preserve his family fortune
you're only going to have one pony now
[Music]
spit off Town Hero Stanley Pines has
fully recovered his memory and will be
throwing a party to celebrate his niece
and nephew's 13th birthday and final day
in town but other than that I can safely
say our beloved Gravity Falls is back to
normal and now Bodacious tea with sports
it's called deathball
I want to play I had only one wish it
would be the shrink all of you with the
shrink ray and bring you home with us in
my pocket but since that's impossible is
that impossible
since that's probably impossible my only
wish is foreign
[Music]
I didn't want to say anything with
everyone listening but we've got a
problem weirdmageddon has been contained
but I'm detecting some strange new
anomalies near the Arctic Ocean I want
to go investigate it but I think I might
be too old to go It Alone Oh I used to
yeah come out they're they're doing it
come on will you give me a second chance
you think we'll find treasure and babes
I'd say there's a high probability but
what should we do with the Mystery Shack
I think the town's had enough mystery
for one lifetime are you thinking what
I'm thinking demolish it me and my nerdy
bro over here have some catching up to
do we're gonna be away for a while
that's why I'm shutting down the Mystery
Shack for good what no it's just that
the shack is the most magical place on
Earth sure the attractions are all fake
but dreams aren't fake like the mermaid
it's not just a dead fish but it's onto
a monkey carcass it's a marvelous
creature that makes us believe that
anything is possible you shut down this
Shack and you shut down our dreams at
least my dreams let them run it come on
Zeus there's no one around to run it
at least there wouldn't be if I hadn't
just found the perfect replacement
oh my God he gets The Fez mystery Jack
is on a new movement
[Applause]
I'll move in immediately yes please
Uncle Stan thanks for wearing my goodbye
sweater ah it's cold out I had to what
but it's like 80 something degrees out
today
hey you mean a lot to me man
you too
uh
oh and this
read it the next time you miss Gravity
Falls
[Music]
nude photos
is that ethical mom and dad won't let me
bring a pig home to California so you
have to stay here
[Music]
come on cool
oh no no no no no no no what the hell
with that ah you know what forget it I
lived with this pig all summer now your
parents are gonna happen
hey boss guy this pig is coming with the
kids now hold on a second bringing
animals aboard a moving vehicle is
strictly prohibited by
e
welcome aboard you can sit in the front
row Pig kids
Knuckleheads were nothing but a nuisance
and I'm glad to be ready
laughs
ready to head into the unknown nope
let's do it that's the spirit
boo boo
[Music]
yeah I'm curious don't wait oh they made
it take a trip
[Music]
just immediately go to kill it
that's enough adventuring standard War
too
foreign
well done that was well ended
indeed ended well
oh look how many summer memories we've
collected
oh yeah him they made it to Summer Of
Love
[Music]
no post credits
that's creepy yeah it's unsettling
that's like the opening of sinister yeah
yeah totally I wonder this looks like an
authentic photograph maybe they made a
Bill Cipher statue and just left it out
somewhere in Oregon for people to find
feels like a we found in the 80s I tried
making a live action movie but they just
made it creepy yeah
this was supposed to be fun and Charming
but instead
it's Five Nights at Freddy's what'd you
think of the finale John I thought it
was very uh thrilling and heartwarming
in equal measure and because from what I
understand this actually has been
separated into two episodes but
originally aired is one hour long finale
and as uh oh [ __ ] we did it wrong well
no I mean like ever since you know it it
aired that way but you know it's it's
kind of for home video and everything
else it's just been separated but even
so I didn't feel like this episode
suffered for that as an episode instead
you know and especially with having to
do a quick reversal with Uncle Stan uh
Grunkle Stan's memories even that didn't
feel overly rushed given what was going
on I mean you know it's still a compact
you know 20 something odd minute episode
but yeah I mean like I'm
it has a feeling of finality because you
know I got the sense during this episode
this you know is aimed at tween's
generally so I feel like they can get
away with a little bit more intensity
and a little bit more of that horror
stuff but especially these last couple
episodes it felt like they have had
carte blanche to like really kind of uh
push that boundary to some extent
because like the stuff at the beginning
The Showdown with Bill Cipher like is
you said Pennywise and I think what's
really cool about bill over the course
of the show has been that he he and his
various hijinks take on from many
different yeah iconic horror villains
and sci-fi characters and stuff and yeah
here it was particularly Pennywise and I
really like the way they've created that
blend because it's it's not so
derivative that it's like oh it's just
what you're doing you know like it feels
like a clever nod while also creating
this holy unsettling gravity uh of its
own
um so yeah like I like like that they
allowed that intensity like they're a
couple times he's like I'm gonna turn
your kids into corpses I'm like it's
pretty harsh
um yeah so like that's yeah that's right
the X stands for extreme uh but uh yeah
going from that side of the episode and
then ending on a truly Bittersweet kind
of tone that is very heartwarming but
that also feels like summer and like
life moving on and summer ending and you
know those kinds of feelings I remember
from especially times when summer was
tied to this sort of you know unique
expanse of a few months where you know
you do things you wouldn't normally do
um yeah I thought this really nicely
paid off all those things and also
leaves you with a hope of like yeah you
know we could come back to this someday
even though as of right now I know we
haven't
but yeah what did you think
I mean you took the boards around my
mouth I think everything you said is 100
accurate they they didn't you know like
take like a Marvel finale
like a season one finale of a Marvel
show yeah this is a series finale and so
weirdly dividing it up knowing the facts
you just presented to me there doesn't
bother me in the way we watched it
because it feel I kind of wonder if I
was like
well we had a finale and three-fourths
of that finale felt like it was
dedicated to some crazy big plot what I
would have wanted a little more focus on
the emotional core of saying goodbye and
wrapping this up
and weirdly enough watching it it's just
one 25 minute episode feels like most of
it was dedicated to the goodbye and said
like you give her to Bill Cipher in the
first 10 and then you focus on the heart
in the last 15.
so to me I feel like okay I got more of
what I would want for your final episode
which is handling that goodbye and
because of the pacing of Gravity Falls
and how it all works it nothing nothing
felt like mundane or perfunctory to me
it felt like it how it would go there's
an episode of Gravity Falls you mean I I
was wondering how like dark and
Bittersweet and melancholic they might
go like I would have believed that they
just let Grunkle Stan never remember
yeah if they wanted to go down that path
and like it was [ __ ] dark but it
would have I I would I was buying it
like oh they just might not remember I
have to start again hour and then they
should just like dissolve to he's dead
and
not only did he not remember he died
soon after cemetery and they're grown up
and his body just won't stay dead
um yeah what I would do right now but
now before I tell you my what I would do
with the sequel which I've already
pitched here
but you know
um I've already pitched my sequel what I
would do what I I really I really did
like that you know they they had a good
emotional resolution and it's it is that
feeling of you never know you might see
them again and there's more Adventure
that awaits them and also the resolve
between
uh the Ford Brothers
wait nope the stand Brothers wait
Stanford Brothers
what is it my God
I mean I guess the Pines Brothers behind
the brothers Stein Brothers yeah because
they're stand forward and Stan Lee
yes and then Stan Lee was pretending to
be Stanford for a long time so thus it
gets confusing two seasons later it's
still hard for me yeah yeah how many who
decides how many fingers everyone has
anyway but the result that they brought
forward there you know from that
brilliant episode were just focused on
their childhood and the paths that went
down
to have it wrap around to something very
just a tangible and heartfelt and uh
yeah it was it was sweet it was really
sweet episodes it was getting the
mystery I think they'd like resolved a
lot
and they
they did they really made it a one for
the memory books with a good sense of
wonder I would do a sequel
I would just make your sequel a live
action movie oh cool it's a live action
movie
starring Dylan O'Brien okay
and and Karen Gillen Karen Gillen why we
we won't get Christian Shaw even though
she would be perfectly available yeah
you get them to return to Gravity Falls
yes
and then you have Paul Giamatti as
Grunkle Stan yeah JK Simmons can still
play foreign
yeah yeah and then uh you could have you
could have Bill Cipher played by Bill
scars Bill Skarsgard is perfect yeah
totally yeah yeah he's coming back where
they believe Bill Cipher is coming back
that's the only thing is Awakening do
yeah he's gotta come back in some way
Jack Black as Zeus yes definitely you
just make a sequel yeah this would be
Wendy still Linda Cardellini huh no dude
Jessica Chastity Jessica
is in an abusive relationship yeah
with Gideon gleeful yeah
played by Billy Eichner
oh I love it dude this pitch is great
I'm telling you guys there's a live
action movie oh dude kind of like how
they made a Goosebumps live action movie
Just instead of doing a remake do a
movie that that takes place after when
they're adults take away the sense of
childhood wonderment have them have kids
have adult yeah yeah make it like kids
and you don't really give a [ __ ] about
them but you know the movie's gonna
focus and make it a combination of the
of the remake of Cheaper by the Dozen
again and also uh uh Hocus Pocus too
they have other kids in there who are
those kids I didn't watch it oh well you
know they're just like three girls who
live in the town who are friends oh
they're not related they're not family
they're not children it's like
Ghostbusters afterlife uh no they're not
related to the Legacy characters in fact
the the protagonist characters there
might be a cameo somewhere but they
don't really show up at all I'm just
talking about the trailer but I think
the movie should be more like Halloween
ends depth or are you just focused on
just a random person and Gravity Falls
going crazy and eventually Awakening
Bill Cipher and have a really really
short-lived Bill Cipher fight at the
very yeah exactly and it's the one-eyed
lady who's Crazy should be the Laurie
Strode sure
um yeah definitely yeah yeah okay so
yeah you you pitch this like the blend
you just like the blend of two red dozen
with one of those Disney movies about
like uh Christopher Robin grew up and
he's cynical now but he needs the kids
to remind him but then yeah make it oh
yeah you could do that and that's why
you know Wendy remembers not Wendy uh
Mabel remembers but Dipper easily it
feels like it might just be a figment of
his imagination yeah the ad firm he
works for is just Zapped his imagination
ironically and now he doesn't remember
any of the journal or anything come on
we gotta go back and reawaken it there
is a decent non-choke version there is
that I think you could do of like good
takes but like a Gravity Falls you don't
have to remake anything just do like a
sequel that's like 10 years later yeah
and Bill's coming back if they how
now I'm trying to think how long has it
been since the show concluded because
because it might it would be 1995. yeah
we're a long past the time they should
have come back then damn we can we could
make it like it where every 27 years we
return to Gravity Falls yeah yeah we're
27 years where there's a new special
hour and a half long
um but live action you could have uh
Mabel played by Keke Palmer yes
and then you could get uh oh dang let's
see
played to look at Elliot page to play
Dipper you have some like other human
[ __ ] guy who's greedy who's like
heard about gravity falls things like
Paul Giamatti and najimari Giovanni
rabisi yeah an avatar yeah yeah who
wants to you know capture and exploit
the truths about gravity falls yeah
there's a movie to make here that is
very cliche but could be but you could
have a unique execution upon it I just
like the idea I like the idea of them
doing a movie that it's not a remake but
one that takes place after yeah and it's
live actions yeah there's a lot of ways
you can do it and it if it isn't the
spirit of like the Goosebumps movie
which I haven't seen but I like the
trailer I like it it's a decent move and
for a kid horror thing it's pretty all
right it being that like it's not
amazing but it's pretty good I liked it
I would recommend checking it out if you
want to have some family Halloween
Trilogy yeah post credit scene Bill
Cipher awakens that's right he cracks
out of that uh statue that he's become
Bill is coming yeah evil dies tonight
evil dies for 40 years Bill Cipher is
terrorized Gravity Falls well
technically there's only two days in the
mid-2000s well you know still evil ties
still awful I'm gonna be the one to kill
him me there's a movie to make here yeah
there's so many movies to make here
yeah none of them even need to be
connected they could all be just
episodic you don't even have to have a
Serial storyline you get so many
celebrity cameos oh my god get rich
Jackman Ryan Reynolds Channing Tatum as
The Gnome right yeah
Dwayne Johnson to show up somewhere as
like an ogre yeah man you get Melissa
McCarthy is the pony yeah okay go-to
players dude Kirsten Wiig to be another
spider lady or something like that yeah
yeah John Mulaney is there it is soon I
am the mayor of Gravity Falls there's
there's a movie to make here yeah I love
it Jason Statham you know is one of like
you know our FBI agent guys I want to
see you in here and he's like he's the
best Cameo he's the funniest one playing
against type oh [ __ ] Will Ferrell Will
Ferrell can be you know somebody who
works for Gideon's uncle
I am I guess he would then just be the
character he plays in uh
that one Danny McBride show where he's
got the blonde hair guys I'm telling you
there's a there's a gravity needs to be
made movie here and I want more yeah do
it do oh dude Blendon blandin so many
time hijinks get get get Justin Roiland
on the case to go come in and stutter a
lot
you could do a live-action sequel show
yeah that would be so cool and think of
this I'm telling you there's ways to
ruin the legacy of Gravity Falls and and
most of them you know would probably
succeed at that but maybe one or two of
them could be great you know the
nightmare realm look at this I'm not
gonna lie if I you guys said don't read
this book because it would spoil [ __ ]
um if you had if I read this I'd
oh I guess I would spoil the brother
coming back yeah that would definitely
suppose yeah he spoke too oh but there's
there's all kinds of things that are not
in the show yeah see look at all you
could draw from this from the live
action follow-up movie they don't give
you the rights to certain things to do
the movie so you pull from this
information book The supplementary try
to make a story with like a rings of
power yeah and I'm telling you there's a
movie to be had here
dude okay oh the shack Tron the Zodiac
okay this is the spoilery part you meant
don't read the the appendices at the
very end okay yeah there's some there's
some spoiler stuff oh my gosh
oh yeah that is the ending of the
brother I take it all back yeah
wow actually looks like a fun book I
know no really I'm so scared to like
actually open it yeah no the drawings
are are lovely and uh like you know this
is one of those I if like especially if
I was the age that this was aimed at
when I first experienced this this is
the kind of book I would love like I
would love to deep detangle the lore and
all that stuff well it's like you could
do three movies that build to Bill
Cipher coming yes and each movie focuses
on the specific types of genre they like
to go into all with a little comedy
slant to it yeah so do like a Twin Peaks
comedy or like yeah they have the
fantasy ones yeah yeah they have the
full-on like horror Supernatural ones
and you got like the crazy sci-fi horror
ons yeah so anything you that the third
one's that one and you build build
Cypher in each of them you build them up
yeah and Henry Cavill shows up at the
end is
[Laughter]
oh God what is what is what does Black
Adam respond
because he responded already he just
looks at him right
yeah I'm pretty sure they shot his
coverage in case you know they're like
we don't know
yeah just just yeah just let's just get
a quick b-roll of you you're good
spoilers are black guy I'm so sorry this
could be anything
um no spoiler for The Rundown hey that
movie kind of holds up it's a great
movie probably is best yeah no it is and
I think it is probably his best shot
yeah no The Rock's best yeah Sean
Williams Scott's character isn't age the
best but you know why he's he's way more
obnoxious than I remember the first time
take time to re-watch the rundown for
some reason I I watched it within the
last year I think it was some some weird
I don't I don't know why I think I think
it was either on or somebody requested
to watch a Dwayne Johnson movie and
that's what we chose
if you want to watch a really rough
movie watch Red notice I want to I bet
it's extra long too because it's a
Netflix movie right
yeah man oh with him and Ryan Reynolds
that's right I didn't think I'd watch
that movie and go gal gadot's the best
actress oh no she's the best actor out
of all
she's actually doing a character did
anybody direct that movie though
yeah Netflix
that's perfect that's perfect it's a
disembodied floating and just like move
back to one
let's make sure the beginning and end of
this are compelling so people will stay
on the service
good plot Twista there's a good twist in
red notice surprisingly I heard that and
I watched I was like oh didn't see
that's what's coming oh good I'm excited
then I'm gonna watch it tonight red
notice
get ready it's the most popular movie of
the year ladies and gentlemen we've done
it thank you for being here hope you
liked our pitch that also simultaneously
[Music]
all right sorry
well it's the last episode we gotta do
yeah
worry about coming back to another
Gravity Falls chances are you you know
already
see y'all soon thanks for being here
much love Gravity Falls is great
[Music]